the British Council has launched this
Shakespeare lives project so in the
British Council in France and in Paris
we are organizing a series of activities
with our students and there will be
studying some of the the plays and
scripts and so on and texts of
Shakespeare so we're looking at two
characters in one scene in the play The
Merchant of Venice and we're going to
make a theater set and you're going to
do a roleplay the art project
incorporates Shakespeare and a diversity
theme around identity because one of the
British Council policies to incorporate
it into language learning and they put
the language in to use using their
theater set I'm not your friend what are
you doing in my garden well what I'm
hoping they'll get out of today really
is that obviously they'll don't know who
Shakespeare was done a little bit about
his life and know about the important
works that he did but also that this
will be an opportunity for them to kind
of explore a little bit about the
concept of Shakespeare's plays the theme
of identity within it whilst also
exploring the kind of English and some
vocabulary and even some kind of grammar
structures that they're going to use to
create a mini dialogue which they'll be
able to take away and also have a little
bit of fun with
this is laura and this is ling okay
Laura I learned how to to to describe
the theater and piece of Shakespeare I
know how to describe and the vocabulary
now the secondary were looking at Romeo
and Juliet and they see a specific scene
and they encounter a discussion between
Juliet and her father when he's asking
her to marry against her will oh my
Romeo is my father he's so selfish you
just want me to we have learned how
agile it was he was angry upset will
never be no I driven i come i really
like today because it was very great and
it's another metro to work I think we
use our imagination and I find this is
great
you